[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello hi hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to we happy few
how you doing is that music a bit loud
that probably is that's the music from
the game I'm gonna turn that down just a
little bit let's try that that's my
answer
hi guys doing welcome to the show
welcome to the game
welcome to everything that we got going
on not welcome to the game but welcome
to this game we're gonna play we happy
for you today but how are you guys doing
you having a good time you happy you're
feeling happy you're feeling the
positive energy running through your
veins I bet you are and I bet you do
yeah take our joy yeah I remember this
game from years ago I only did one video
on it a while while back bailey lindblum
i just wanted to tell you how much of an
amazing person you are well I doubt that
incredibly but thank you so much for the
super chat and Thank You Rachael cooler
you were my hero mark and you always put
a smile on my face well thank you so
much and thank you everybody that has
become a member of the channel I think
everybody this has been supporting me
I've got other stuff already on route
after Wilfred war stache video I've
already got the next thing in plan and
it's gonna be really cool and I think
you guys are gonna like it but that's
not the point for today today we are
going to be playing this game right here
yeah there we go
okay so we're gonna be playing we happy
fuse the volume good volume good volume
okay if you're watching this in the
future don't be confused I just decided
to livestream this one because I wanted
to give it a good try I did one video a
while back when they was certainly in
development but now I wanted to play it
again so yeah good yeah when does it
come out this game has already come out
so if you want to play this you can play
it right now I don't know when
specifically it came out but yeah the
game is good yeah volume is good so I
don't know what to expect because last
time that I played this it was just kind
of an early intro to it you got the
concepts of the game and it's gonna be
interesting to see how much has changed
since it actually came out a long time
ago or when it first got released as a
demo a long time ago and now that it's
in its full release welcome ace Timon
thank you so much yeah and thank you
uhit's Ruby dooby and that fit oh my
goodness thank you guys so much for
being here on this one we're gonna have
fun today maybe
I don't know we're gonna be happy unless
the happiness is actually all fake and
it's not really about happiness and it's
about something much more sinister which
would probably be the case but let's do
this new game everybody buckle up Oh
easy whoa custom Oh easy you're here for
a story or two to explore strange new
world people will be less suspicious of
you and you will be getting plenty of
warning before they become a regressive
you enjoy a challenge people will be
suspicious of you and you'll need to
learn the rules to blend in you enjoy a
good fight in a harsh world where
survival is not guaranteed satisfying
your basic needs will take more effort
in time and people will generally be
hostile why would they be hostile in
this lovely beautiful world why would
they be hostile let's just go with
normal because I have no idea what else
again not yet why would I begin probably
happy people have no past but that seems
odd I don't know oh
press spacebar okay this is it bb-but oh
I wasn't supposed to read that
okay I see so this is my job's heavens
oh whoops can't have anybody not
swimming in the river so I don't know
much about the story of this game so I
have no idea
hasting brothers win scrap gathering
breath first of all an Arthur Hastings
[Music]
I should just take my joy okay all right
wait what would happen if I take the joy
what happened if I just what would
happen if I take the joy I should I
should that's what these games all about
right taking the joy having a good time
I don't want to remember my memories are
terrible why would they why would I ever
bring that up to me oh yeah subtitles
let me get those on real quick good call
good call good call let me get those I
would be graphic now would game Baba -
Bubba - Bubba - Bubba - Bubba - Bubba -
Bubba - Bubba - Bubba - Bubba - Bubba -
Bubba - Bubba - Bubba - Bubba - Bubba
language options here we go BAM
small outline medium outline let's go
medium sound captions may be that good
to be helpful I'm not a hundred percent
sure let's go a small outline actually
sound captions News Ticker what does
that even do sign captions yeah we're
good on that one okay all right good
let's do that alright what would happen
if we just take the joy there like a
save option now I can't even save again
I'm gonna take it
I like these pills there's bills look
pretty tasty if I gotta say one of those
dumb right this is a choice happiness is
it you're right you're hundred percent
right about that I just squash that no
no no no it's known as drunk snug as a
bug on a drug yep that's you know that
there we go well I think we all learned
something here today that was that was
sublime I'm so happy that we did that
now we're fine and everything's good so
don't worry about anything well you know
what just thank you everybody so much
for being here for her to smash that
like button
slap that Bell on the ass and be sure to
comment any other ludicrous things that
you want to say great game great game
everybody just give it up for the give a
round of applause to this great game
great game all right I'm gonna get out
of here I'm gonna go I don't know what
I'm gonna do all right let's try that
again
happy is the country with no past whoa
Wow is it oh wow that's good all right
let's try that again
all right what would happen if we gotten
to the end of the credits I don't know
probably nothing special produce would
have gone to the main menu or something
right there would that have done
anything if I got to the end of the
credits maybe best thing ever
yeah I know great game great game great
game great good thank you Alex D G thank
you so much thank you puggy Thank You
Josh Carter
can I get did you find the secret ending
was that a secret ending I mean it seems
like the true ending if you ask me about
anything of this we don't need to
remember nothin
[Music]
hmm what time here it is this game
probably around
I would guess like 1960s something like
that 1960s 70s just judging by like the
pictures of jewels of people's uh like
clothing and whatnot all right here we
go
Wow we took the joy last time so let's
take it again just to make sure it
doesn't real thing now let's remember
get out of here
do that Hey all right very subtle about
that Percy
oh the calendar says 1964 okay well that
explains it I was very old no one's seen
you for hours then why haven't I heard a
single whoosh through the door since 10
o'clock did you forget we're having dear
to his birthday party we've got a pinata
right of course
well come on then then don't take too
long to finish
mmm don't that smile afterwards Oh get a
new one
take Deepa why do I seem so uncertain
I'm not very good at faking anything is
this like a co-worker or is this this is
my home no it must be my coworker okay
take empty buy or sell how do I use my
legs do I get do I stand do I go
here we go I did it thank you I love
what you've done with your office it's
so homey yeah you know I like Holmes
Sherlock Holmes Stockholm Syndrome I
like all the Holmes you are all so
homely so anyway I'm just uh
uh-huh there we go got it you don't need
to stare at me I'm my father's common
touch so could you just pretend that I
know how to motivate you uh I don't want
your common touch to be perfectly honest
um so I'm just gonna like I'm just gonna
back away slowly because I don't like
any part of this conversation here
anyway slippity to bob boink
[Laughter]
except document or sensor oh she's still
there that's what we'll do
big boo pickable be couple people people
I love this game makes me so happy
peekaboo the whole game a big boo
[Music]
peekaboo okay anyway should I accept it
or censor it I'm gonna I mean there's no
benefit to anybody else if this isn't
censored I just think it's more stuff
that could get me caught right so I know
it I know this so according to my job I
should censor this right yeah that makes
sense to me yeah I'm supposed to be
coming back today okay oh wait where's
pickup where where's the peekaboo go
okay general Bing a clarifies
registration procedure didn't know Ben
Gunn promotion the municipal laser laser
you love the occupational acuity
applicable parades tweet wait last night
to speak to a crowd of citizens
originally requesting clarification for
the new route I will use waking rule as
most Wellingtonians know by now oh the
children will be under the age of 13 by
July 22nd must be registered with the
authority general been clarified that
the deadline for registration is next
Tuesday he will fuse to speculate on
your watch allow for your registration
evaluation I love the word registration
regulation
I cannot illuminates the regulations any
further because Colonel von Stauffenberg
has not informed me of its purpose
[Laughter]
I'm sorry but I'm not stopping I imagine
that hope that did something to do with
maintaining nutrition far out were
injured when in this time of scarcity
but you have not told me to expose it
they remind me that crowd that the
occupation high so far been
extraordinary orderly and peaceful and
yet citizen continued obedience to ego
orders of the way is crucial to
maintaining goodwill with our fishing I
don't know anyway probably fine
I don't even ever says turbine oh I
don't know man look I don't know what
I'm doing it seemed fine can turn up the
game yeah I can do that yeah let me hang
on one second here I turned it down cuz
the music on the main screen was a
little low let me get let me crank it
back up let's go just pull perfect love
it thanks guys I am too please drug
trials a qualified success or sorry
Robert
the first one no the first round of
trials of new male and anti melancholic
medication have been qualified success
sated dr. Alexander acting head of the
MILCON River Bruce melancholic feelings
in 28 out of 32 respondent rats
despondent rats
oh those depressed rats despondency can
be induced in rats by repeatedly giving
electrical shocks oh that's why they're
despondent oh okay
alright sure we're gained fifty percent
sure this seems good right right
Yeah right oh yeah I know everybody's
sure I know I'm right what are you
talking about I know I'm right
no canister well take this with me
standing up E and
yeah I'm out of here baby okay locked
empty empty all right cool
whoa the canister wonders what life's
like outside the tube of course he'd
have to break the cheat to get help
well I won't break it for everybody
oh no is this symbolism oh no is this an
analogy is this something that pertains
to the situation I'm in if I wanted to
be free I gotta break it for everybody
I'm fine with that
yeah Oh earth whistle you're off at the
party aren't ya yes Oh miss Byng has
written Clive a letter it is so
thoughtful of you to suggest how to best
rearrange the department I am always
grateful for suggestions from junior
staff without a best to do my job as
director however I am afraid that it
would be just destabilizing to swap your
office with that of mr. Hastings
fortunately turnover in this department
is high if Prue doesn't return soon I
don't see why you couldn't have her
office in the meantime I suggest you pop
another join you'll feel the sunshine on
your face whether you have a window or
not take that Clive you little [ __ ]
okay oh that's me saying that alright
well alright then search empty
alright there's no point in that I'm
very unhappy now okay what is that a
cricket bat broken bottle okay fun stuff
oh I could sense her more documents you
could also take some joy I guess where's
that music coming from oh oh that's me
alright wait a minute what a douchebag
okay I don't know if there's a point to
searching anything just yet but I'm very
meticulous about everything that I'm
doing a almost City let's see oh yeah I
must do things wrong that especially
considering I definitely know how to do
things wrong and I'm gonna don't want
doing wrong here we go farm workers
expected to return from Germany huh yeah
right sensor that one I put it down oh
boy I thought I was supposed to do bad
work censoring what sounded like good I
don't know what taxi service restored on
three wheels is it good Jewish bad
Wellington under reopens if I did that
right but I'll take that bar so thank
you very much okay someone requested
bigger bigger subtitles let's try medium
see how that do hello do you did it dude
Liddy Oh Oh
need a lockpick okay well I'll get that
later hello
whatever happened to you did you not
take your your joy Oh
well it's real depressing in here it was
to be a mist of not happy - oh yeah
alright let me search through your [ __ ]
I'm sure there's what he would have
wanted okay do i what happens if I do
everybody's alright whatever I don't I
still don't know I hope our okay well
hey easy enough along uncle Bolshevism
against Europe gala a smash approved oh
look at that nice family oh so nice with
their faces yeah babies waiting tripe a
tribe strong ok her to turn in your
automotive oh let's censor oh he doesn't
even bothered saying anything more I'm
probably wrong on all this take the joy
why would I take the joy Margaret
birthing will open battle of flowers
yeah ok
seems good to me maybe it's just a
simple thing of like anything that's not
happy no no please arrest for in reader
riot a breeder riot oh there's no word
on the condition of her baby whose birth
was not expected for another two months
well let's just prove that right there
that's probably fine people need to know
people need to know yeah I have no idea
well whatever alright I did that I'm
very happy about that I did that there's
empty empty nothing anything for you
well you know coming back oh you / where
did you go where did you go where did
you go
that's a good question where did you go
I took my joy hey Harley Dooley oh um
hey how's it going there
whoa you're you are smiley hey wait oh
hey hi howdy ho D okay all right we'll
see you I'll just sit here and wait for
you just rest in the future Wow
celebrations plan for joy Hanover's whoa
cool spell oh they seem to be a bit
behind you know work now that you
mention it yeah a little bit all right
well good for us then that just means
more opportunity to be happy happy happy
did I take the power cell wait did I
take the power cell out of that other
room let me go back real quick I need I
need to make sure I got that yeah I
didn't I didn't see stupid me give me
that give me that give me that give it
it I got these power cells I don't know
what these power cells before but I got
him and so long as I got him I can feel
like I actually I'm doing something in
my life which I'm not
I can feel
okay thank you dr. Jack thank you thank
you for that thank you thank you doctor
ah no nothing well okay well well that's
what they say to me when they find me I
can't tell if that's laughing or crying
hello
there you are you nearly missed the
pinata it's the most adorable Spanish
custom Uncle Jack did a whole show about
it
you smash it until all the sweets come
out come on hit it
okay did it all hit the crap out of it
whole year let me give this a whack
[Music]
who you are of your joy take one of mine
oh my lord
these are down security we've got a
downer that's me that's me baby
always down all the time they call me
good old DTF down to fun right hey
you're annoying what happens if I wait
it's a pretty good chance take your toy
take your joy thank your Joe oh thank
you baby Kirby thank you so much take
your joy take your joy take your joy
take your joy I like it it's like it's
got a good ring to it
okay all right I guess I could get out
of here I was hoping that they'd
eventually just actually uh-huh they
would act oh don't forget the latter hey
take your joy
hey yo joy hey you're doing okay bye
anyway Oh things are gonna be there
forever what if I'm gone and they're
just still there by the door and
security comes by there's still book nor
joy and like they can't help the
security even comes as like hey you guys
chanting about joy here good go toy dark
your joy okay thank you
oh I'm gonna break it I'm gonna break it
all Wow I think I just rammed my face
into that oh okay
toot-toot-toot toot-toot-toot they gotta
do that right now yeah well forget it
there's no time oh okay all right was
there a gas leak cuz I pulled the pipe
off to toot toot toot toot toot toot
this is what they're gonna be the entire
time that they go through this game
that's all I'm gonna hear buy some tripe
feed your baby they played me dirty I
don't know about that I mean I I'm the
one that whacked that rat real good I
guess
generating world planting foliage
planning patrols plague wastrels can
give you plague if they hurt you I want
plague that sounds awful why would I
want plague I don't want to do that then
is that does that include hurting me
emotionally cuz I'm a very fragile soul
oh Christ
chase me no bridges right there tunnels
I'm pretty sure I'm not in the parade
anymore I don't even think I'm still in
the village I don't think I don't think
we went that far it's sealed in that way
are you sure about it take your toy
okay fine then alright I'll go little
not because you want me to but because I
want me to Barrow home distribution no
caution wait this may contain corrosive
substances don't drink okay what if I
drink a toast what if I drink it I need
tell me cool take your joy take your joy
take your joy
alright fine then boys over here can I
go here no [ __ ] oh please seem to
have locked me in hmm I suppose they're
worried about the gas terribly
thoughtful of them quick go joy okay
do not open Authority Authority
personnel only
I did it Oh candy candy candy where's my
candy where'd you go I know you've got
candy in here somewhere
I don't think that I'm gonna forget
about you candy in here Punk candy in
the candy in here come on rat take your
joy she ran this way I wonder if I'll
see her again
hmm
okay empty pill bottle those are gotta
be worth something if I drink from that
they probably put joy in the water I'd
imagine that's probably no good okay and
I lost my chance for more candy
real sad about that bobby pin yes please
is that one that was obviously five you
can craft things in the menu tie string
was out of your journal okay tie string
okay are you certain Teddy's off his joy
perhaps he merely forgot you always
you've got to look after your mates man
have you tried to tying a string around
his finger that always helps me anyway I
can't resign Teddy because I haven't got
a replacement on all the juniors our
office Cargill the substance has been
severing all sorts of connections the mo
Deline must flow okay but ty ring around
the figure all right sure prudence ohms
was this a mistake it seems so clever to
disappear first rather than trying to
brazen my way across the bridge after
enough joy they'd forget they'd ever
known a prudence Holmes beastly Clive
would take my office and they'd forget
anyone else was ever in it but now that
I'm here I wonder should I have put my
trust in mr. kite and where are his
bloody instructions in the abandoned
house yes but which abandon house
they're all abandoned how to deal with
all these wastrels my god they look like
something out of Dante we chase someone
out whenever they'd make they wouldn't
take their joy but we never really
thought about where they went when I
knew we chase them out when joy made
them sick but I didn't know it was here
to starve and weep and remember I
assumed they were all sent to the
sanatorium a decent hospital but I
suppose that's what I wanted to believe
we were all complicit we know without
knowing and don't want to remember so we
don't let her live terrible handwriting
dear doctor director Bing one of your
employees must is a subversive and maybe
even a downer
I overheard him in the commissary
telling a friend that he thinks that his
job redacting old articles is silly and
what's so scary about the truth he's a
very tall and slim with black hair and
brown eyes and glasses I know I
shouldn't should have asked his name but
I am a naturally shy woman and ability
today a shy woman are you Clive or just
a nasty manipulative schemer all right
dear mr. Burge whistle it is so soft
well oh wait no I knew that one already
what were you thinking
author you've gone and done it now
haven't you not only rather spectacular
quit your job but now you're a downer
the town's folk will unleash the hounds
or they would if we hadn't eaten them 20
years ago the wastrels do not seem
terribly friendly I hope they aren't
really cannibals oh god I'm one of them
now aren't I
I've got to get out of oh this is a
letter to myself Oh what in dog's name
were you thinking huh Percy I saw his
picture from just before we put them all
on the train God all that horrible
grinding steel in the screamed how he
must hate me
why did I tell the Jerry's I was already
13 they were only off by 10 days
why didn't I keep my mouth shut and get
on the train and go off to Germany with
him like I promised him I can't remember
but I promised him that's gotta mean
something I've got to find Percy
wherever he is and make sure he's okay
how long have we been eating rats hope
some candy walks across my way soon okay
anyway so I can craft a bunch of things
but I don't know if I've got anything
that I need to craft yet and if I did I
wouldn't want to waste anything crafting
just yet because I don't know what I
need so let's go out here Oh some books
and it's a metal to make a long Pig
alright
press tab alright crafting I'm assuming
it's a hammer I just got a hammer proper
shooting nice all right Jimmy bar
lockpick alright let's do this BAM done
all right I'm gone let's dig us is it a
salamander of me getting into constant
trouble finally payoff
a salamander who's the salamander
salamander Hey okay nothing okay
electroshock er that's nice
I'll take that uh your combo and mate oh
I am very strong all right Rupert
all right rupee oh wow I don't know what
this is but Rupert all right i'ma lay
you gently down here all right Ruby look
at that happy expression of a Bullis ah
okay what is this no one's going to hurt
you
Percy I I promise but if I heard the
city I don't think I blow anything else
up why because we surrendered the hope
what are we going to do offer we'll look
out for each other okay all right so
this is some kind of alternative
universe after World War two
all right Rupert is that uh how close am
i yeah say it warm we're cold will play
they're gonna play all hot hot warm cold
game all right what we got Thor of
Theodore miner all right well I don't
really want to read somebody's diary but
I looked in the lights doctor's orders
shadows all around always around the
corner to joy so I could stand his ugly
face why won't it work swap them out for
paracetamol jelly beans we haven't had
jelly bean since have we ever had jelly
beans I hate when he talks in that slow
condescending voice what's wrong with my
joy he scratch he's scratching away in
the corner scribble scribble whoosh of a
pneumatic tube he's blaming it all on me
what happened isn't he he says it's his
missus I don't believe he's still got a
missus with his big mossy teeth I bet
she went on holiday long ago was I
married Oh can hear him crunching in the
dark it isn't rats it's his big mossy
teeth he's got candy he's got some candy
Liz I'm trying to weasel out of this one
I saw him riding those lies reassigned
me off my joy huh welcome to the home to
vertigo and welcome
welcome to the end of our time now
doesn't chant as well I like take your
joy
that's much better right rupee yeah you
know I'm talking about yeah Ruby come on
all right when you craft you can use any
items in your pneumatic stash no matter
where they are
oh no can I put Rupert in my pneumatics
ash do I do that I mean not exactly like
I need to but you know let's go to know
that's good to know all right boy Oh
Rupert come on now I've got plenty of
joy I've got you you're the only joy I
need in my life locked that's is not
right let's see about crafting another
lockpick I probably shouldn't waste them
like this but I don't know any better so
why not
alright Ripper I got a drop you for a
second rope your head you okay you okay
Ruby all right okay whatever
oh but I thought oh really an elegant
hack okay all right Ruby come on we
gotta go come on we got it I've covered
a roofie all right what's in this room
Oh your joy take your joy time Ted take
your joy take your noise my life back
your joy here comes your joy in the
shape of my fists Keep Calm point take
your jaw that's the first fun I've won
since primary school that's nothing it's
the first fire penises brothers school
huh all right well thank you thank you
thank you for that I appreciate it
priests hard priests Oh Rupert
he was watching he who's cheering me on
from the doorway Ruby oh thanks man
I knew you always had my back you could
IIIi know if I hadn't handled it you
would have swooped right in taking care
of it right away but Ruby I appreciate
art you watch the door for me
you watch the door rupee okay all right
what do we got here button love it press
it
Oh root we may not be able to follow Oh
No
roofie oh wait what's up here anything
up here that I need to know about none
of these seem to be searchable okay what
about climbing okay here we go so what's
in here roofie you watch the door
you make sure nobody comes in all right
I'll see him in a bit never abandon it
whoa I don't like the mysterious glowing
white substances rotten carrot hell yeah
some per rupee all right oh that's a lot
of whatever I'll take that all right
well another run carrot Oh on the ground
okay got that
all right thank you thank you roofie I
got us some carrots you're gonna love it
well another one not rotten I'll save
that for me Ruby don't mind the rotten
ones he actually likes them with his big
mossy teeth and all that yeah he's got
this hi Ruby look look I got us carrots
Ruby please carrot good okay sorry I
meant to give you a carrot carrot how do
I gotta throw a carrot come on there's
got to be a way to throw a carrot food
carrot drop there you go right there
rupee all right you get it whenever
you're hungry if you're not hungry now
it's fine Andrew
okay I guess we out II don't have any
other hatches to go to just yet
fast travel you say okay alright then
oh no I'm not going oh no all right
rupee you got to watch this door for me
if Theodore gets up give them a good old
joy get mom a fistful of joy that's what
we're all about here you make sure he
gets his joy wink wonk okay anyway yeah
okay all right here we go
this is a horror game I'm not on
represent sure yeah not a hundred
percent sure the breach gotta get to the
bridge in the parade district which I
just got chased out of brilliant really
ah the train station if I can get to the
train station I can just follow the old
rail tunnel all the way to the bridge be
nice if there was a map with me I
suppose back in those days we could
remember where things were I don't know
about that that doesn't seem to dude Oh
what the hell Carol it's Tamez what the
hell wait why is it just a dead body
right there oh they're just dead bodies
all over the place here I'm not I wasn't
sure
okay seems like this place has seen a
few better days but so far not too
horrible one lakh Oh a rock perfect
perfect
weapons will break after repeated use it
also upset people when you carry them
around openly you meet my rock people
honestly people gonna be upset if I have
a rock around here oh come on now it's
just a rock a rock it's all I got
alright I don't even know how to Oh God
everyone back off I've got my rock
alright what happens if I don't just eat
it no it's gonna eat it right away do I
need to do this I probably do numb Hey
yeah whatever I know I'm a rock I put
away my rock okay
man this place looks still war-torn and
I guess that's the point right
Surrender Dorothy I mean Lindy well I'm
up here now hope hope hope hope can I
get down here whoa again alright is this
where I'm supposed to go or is this not
where I'm supposed to go I have no idea
but I don't care I'm coming for you
[ __ ]
I haven't got it all figured out but I
will find you
yes yes I will yes I absolutely will oh
[Music]
well that's weird collect to Gilead
petals travel to the train station hmm
oh-oh-oh
ah take that okay goddamnit I need to
hit the read button D party do come to
your foot in your finery remember your
manners ah search this kettle ah blue
current perfect rotting meat perfect
lava doesn't give me food poisoning so
bad don't worry about that okay nice
helmet nice golden cat statue that's
that's real nice wonder if my parents
would be proud of me what would they be
terribly stunned I'm not sure what you
talked about I think you've got more
problems than just what you see in front
of your face and your parents thoughts
of how you are Church campfire all right
I don't know what I'm supposed to do
with all this stuff like I don't I don't
know the true scope of this game so I'm
not a harm percent you or what I'm gonna
need and what I'm gonna need it
I'm gonna learn obviously whoo Juliet
Percy told me about these they're good
for wounds and things maybe I can make
some sort of ointment to put on my
wounds oh yeah I'm gonna make an
ointment for my wounds Oh Huff's and
puffs well I don't like that don't like
that at all okay
why what happened here I mean it's
obviously this place was bombed in this
post war but nobody actually built
anything about it there's another body
that's recent though
oh don't know why that required an
orchestral string sorry yeah I've done
this already I shouldn't be too sorry
about it your courage your cheerfulness
your resolution will bring us victory
seems like we lost already a long time
ago I don't think there's any victory
left to get yeah okay no nothing to
search I don't even know if there's a
point to be searching all these
different places still I never told me
what I especially said the one in London
when they took him to see what
specialists are you talking about I
can't jump up there come on I want to
get up there there's something maybe
it's just the drawings on the walls all
right I'm just gonna head towards the
interior of town and then I'm gonna jet
back once I don't say whoa oh okay oh no
these are the diseased people posed to
me that the locals may not be all that
welcoming oh dear let's try not to get
killed shall we okay all right I mean
eating I am let us in or let us out okay
all right well big maybe you should be
more decisive uh hello
anyone out there are you a tourist
you're dressed like one [ __ ] slumming
are we must be nice to have a closet
I'm already in coach you're new here
aren't you from the parade yes
well a lot how could you tell yeah I'll
tell you how to survive your next five
minutes and in return you'll give me
your socks
that's outrageous your funeral
fair enough good sack so angry because
that scent you're wearing reminds them
of all the jolly proper decent wellies
who drove a mare of the ohms in the
village and now we're all cold and tired
and starving to death
you better get a nice sharp Rock and rip
that to shreds
I got a rock and gave this to me for
Christmas although reputa straits [ __ ]
good good point B so many yeah it's not
the latest groovy nightclub is new
people get a bad batch of joy and it
like flips a switch and they can't take
join you more so they get chased out of
the village been a little bad batches
lately so what happens if I rip up my
suit they invite me over for tea and
biscuits then they really won't give a
damn what you do so long as you don't
take things that don't belong to you
well go up and punch someone in the nose
mmm
now you can survive the next five
minutes cheerio okay thank you
but what if I don't want to I have
standards to maintain about my own
appearance you know what I mean all
right whatever maybe I do have to but
maybe you're just a jerk huh whoa
another memory yeah weird
my light for you today at 4:15 that's
not good Percy rubbish applying I was a
good lie today who did you lie to mrs.
Boyle mrs. Boyle came here her face was
all red and and her voice was like mom
when she's angry and I fought but you
would ask me why she's angry
why was she angry I decided that she was
ain't but I decided that she was angry
because you were up in a tree because
the Sally boy was bedroom window last
night at 8:15 p.m. oh bloody hell why
exactly did he say I told of it I was in
forgery Oh Percy was very bad no offer
it's brilliant
why is he brilliant she went with me
being trouble I'm so low he didn't have
to do that she told me not to do it
again so I promised I wouldn't thank you
I love you Arthur I love you too why
pardon me huh do you drop some acid what
are you talking about trying to
supplement your joy workbench I already
have now I'll make another one of these
done a torn suit oh I don't want to but
then I won't be able to where to conform
and mm-hmm
no but I don't want you I don't okay
fine I'll tear up my suit you don't know
I have standards I have standards I'm
not gonna do it I'm better I'm gonna
take these rocks it's carrying too many
rocks I've got my rocks I'm gonna wait
bust out my rock you're my rock
you see my rock hey lady watch it Rock
see that well okay I think lost forever
does it sometimes you just have to eat
rotten things that's life in it
okay thank you all right sure sleeping
all right they look sick and they
suddenly become wild dogs at least we're
alive
right did you get it cut out here you'd
better bandage it up you can get an
infection
just from a scratch okay could be worse
I think okay if you can help it
shut them away and just run as fast as
you can hello I shove at least we have
our memories right sometimes I hear
horsemen at night it's before talking to
you is super fun I suppose if there's
something valuable in this house it
ought to be in here well why would I
steal it
oh that's a bit risky the cooperative
Goldilocks
oh why would I steal it I don't wanna
steal it I can make without stealing it
what's in here turlet this is where the
pooping room back in 1964 people read
books to learn how to do things better
okay whatever you say you are just a
delight to talk to all right what is
this where's this book where book book
where book book book all book did I get
a book I thought I picked up the book I
know I picked up a book I know I picked
up a book learn my book when the book
where'd my goddamn book where is my I
don't have a book here there was book
I said sir comic book there's no book
book book go
[Music]
look where the book in a book we're in a
book where the buck go
where did a book where's my book I just
picked up a book you told me to read the
book I wanted to read a book hard but I
could stay here forever at least until
our staff to this yeah something like
that
all right I'll just be in here in the
trash where I belong where's my book
all right got all that that's good all
right search camp fire nothing well they
sure are rowdy out there wonder what
would happen with I can't save the game
why can't I save the game is that just
not allowed is there anybody's still
angry out there they're not saying take
my joy rate okay I don't know where the
book went but I guess it's fine I know I
don't want to tear my suit though I
don't want it's a nice suit my uncle
gave it to me our Altair fine but you'd
know that this is gonna change me
whap all right there we go I think my
suit is decent anymore good word around
the garden district but proper folk let
me peg for a waste war mm say hey did
you know the rotten donor like us be
aware that some actions cause instant
aggression like trespassing or stealing
it's judge me oh whoa oh yeah holding up
getting enough sleep it's important to
sleep sure is sure is pal
sure is buddy anyway you all look so
down together miss bings close daddy get
off sleep it's important to sleep this
too shall pass
um I finger gunned him out of existence
and he was there and then he was not
there
all right okay anyway how you feel
do ya where I can see you no one likes
lie hello peculiar you alright I trying
that you talk about sometimes I can't
help it
you're doing a dance are we dancing take
your joy take your joy I guess alright
anyway at least there were flowers out
here
it doesn't make you anything
been a while isn't it the worst of it is
we did things the Germans didn't even
ask us to do he all right it's too late
to say you're sorry
how would he know why should he care at
least there are flowers out here flowers
did white tree Park she would talk to me
how are you holding up these two shower
pumps well nothing lasts forever
does it don't go he was boxes just
because they're not looking all right at
least we have our memories right
sometimes you just have to eat rotten
things that's life in it
yep that's life okay I'm out of here you
carry on with oh oh oh
you better you okay you all right okay
she's better now you take care but do LA
but do you take care alright see ya
the lower of God boots see ya loose it
pop a squat mmm yeah it's good just like
a proper downer
um can I jump over this nope okay well
that I don't think I want to go there
anyway anyway hurry
you still there patootie oh oh yeah
Pachulia okay still doing your dance
well this guy's lucky I guess but I'll
see you around what was the point of
even coming here
wow this place is bull oh there's all
town's inflicted by at the time today
and in June right mr. Churchill getting
a bit thirsty I better find something to
drink where's a pub when you need one Oh
when you could soon food your maximum
stamina increases for a short time when
you're too hungry your Maximus damn it
decreases when you drink the COS of
spending is reduced when you were too
thirsty sprinting okay well ignoring
this won't kill you do try to remember
to eat and drink so you can benefit from
nutrition okay all right you you you you
you you sitting here sitting or me just
having a bit of a sit down
[Laughter]
I've been sleeping alright I've seen an
apple go rotten in my hand alright that
answered my question uh you know I'm
gonna take this rancid stew let's go get
out of here whoo whoo whoo all right
mckiddy out of here like it's gonna move
on pretend like I was never here never
was gathering night blooming Nonsuch
requires night I should have guessed
pretty better find something to drink
[Music]
it's not so bad once you get used to it
I suppose
sit pop squads like old man's like home
mom okay anyway feather in the ashes
whew I remember oh god I remember I'm
not a downer there's no excuse for those
people I'd take joy happily if I only I
could oh god I wish I could without
peeking my guts up
how could Joey work for years and then
cruelly stop I missed the butterflies
and rainbows must think of the
butterflies and rainbows not the horrors
that push into my head I miss Hamlin
village I strained my ears for the sound
of Simon Says across the water
growing up I can wait to get out and see
the world now all I want is a couple of
teams to stop feeling it slept all day
yesterday maybe two days the great blurs
into itself the flowers in the garden
district mocked me bursting with color
in the place of misery why do they cast
us out of the village what's it to them
if I can't take joy it should make them
all the happier knowing they can Oh God
I remember what we did
[Music]
we're some music come is there another
floor up oh god damn it
keeps doing that I keep getting to hit
it and I go enough with the bleeding
heart editorials the agitators that were
hanged had it coming if they had
destroyed the register of children the
whole town would have been destroyed
stick to reporting the football scores
and save the editorializing
we don't need police looking for every
Tom Dick and Harry that took care of
those outlaw parents what did the police
going to do arrest the old town maybe I
must vigorously disagree with the recent
editorial regarding the vigilante
actions against the saboteurs these
selfish parents attempted to destroy the
registry of children so that their own
would not have to be hostages their
actions were a slap in the face of every
family that has a send a son off to war
we must all do our duty by long English
tradition cowards are hanged
to encourage the others surely saboteur
cowers deserve no better all right miss
Bing we've heard a lot about Miss Bing
yeah saboteurs swing justice or mob
violence and a good question I guess
they were so small
I guess oh that's terribly romantic
isn't it I had each other to the end oh
[Music]
okay all right
I'm guessing that what they remember is
something about like something that
happened to the children of this town
like something about the children so
that they couldn't like they couldn't
deal with the pain that must have been
killing children that's the only thing
that it could have been right thanks to
a bit of British ingenuity the Bell pit
brothers who were too ill with measles
to take the train last week will be able
to join their playmates after all
general bings office dispatched a taxi
to drive the youngsters to Bristol where
they arrived just in time to board the
German ocean liner taking them to berm
Bremerhaven it was certainly a challenge
to find a working taxi in these times
notes general but we must all go above
and beyond the okuu truant wishes the
bell pit boys a bon voyage aboard the
st. Louis yeah I don't know what that
means I don't know what any of that
means
yeah sorry I'm just gonna sorry
rotten petit you got a rotten potato
when you believe I'm doing this
yeah do what you gotta do to survive I
guess I could take them down right good
night
well just that easy yeah okay and I'm
sorry that was awfully disrespectful but
this is the best I can do
anyway um alright see ya okay bye
okay so we got some stuff hmm smoking
weed everyday we got some stuff but uh
took some took some doing to get to I
don't think there's anything left here
yeah we've already searched everything
in the yard let's
here oh it's almost night oh that's
right it could actually be night in this
oh no it's not almost night it just
looked almost night okay whatever yeah
to respect him I must eat them but don't
waste anything
yeah I'm sure worse things have happened
in this universe but maybe not would it
what am i vision go black right there Oh
what's glowy over there
Oh what's glowy I don't know what's
glowy but let's find out nothing
distinctly a glowy oh come on
I find that ok hmm nothing all right
let's just go towards the objective
that's enough wandering around let's get
to the train station so that we can
carry on with the actual main story of
it we'll be exploring more later but I
don't want to do too much I'm not gonna
be completing to sell shoes to get back
home to village well I well I live in
the parade now you won't get past that
door not without one of them disposable
electrical cars they're all the bobbies
off and a Power Cell good parasol where
I could mug a Bobby oh you're a brave
one aren't you
no I'll trade you one time you want to
go back home home to all those bastards
who chased me out meows when they all
catch the player can die then I'll go
back ok a whole lot more those bastards
in that camp over there with the helmets
for the proper weapons they took
something from me you get them back for
me
I'll give you me Caird sounds quite
dangerous isn't it
of course it's bloody dangerous that's
what I'm paying you can't fire me isn't
that sort of Hamlet over there will
tread alright well what are they your
medals been the wall I want the deer
sore at Dunkirk and the Victoria Cross
it Rams gear that was busted it was
funny I still Adam [ __ ] foot it I
thought it was no I didn't lead a Power
Cell to fire this thing up
Hudak install monster doors - right well
I'll see what can do cachi I'll think
what I'll see what I can do well if I go
to a camp of robbers yeah definitely
defeat them with my right be a short
wait yeah well I'm gonna and my my
chance they're pretty scary a thank you
so much to albedo cipher and Beth Brown
for giving $500 for super chat thank you
so much but you don't need to do that I
don't want to get into big conundrum
about this but seriously you don't need
to do that I appreciate it so much but
not necessary at all thank you all so
empty closets Kane Wainwright Beale
ciphers animation slender guy 56 with
$200 to super chat stay happy mark
everyone else is thank you so much JD
King WWE Spencer Cochran thank you so
much like but totally unnecessary like
it don't need it at all it's all good
unlock nothing in there nothing in here
car in case I didn't remember
okay so head boys there are many doors
head boys live it's a body fortress
it's alright ISO right there's probably
a back entrance somewhere that's alright
it's all I wants this watch this Dane
never gonna know never gonna yeah here
we go
never gonna know see all her butt debris
buddy bobbidi boo they're never gonna
know who am you I don't know I guess I
guess these aren't searchlights warning
I'm trespassing well you know que sera
sera and all that there's something down
here I can't go that way ah alright
whatever
cuz I'm down at whoa um why do you have
a blade pointed at the entrance it's a
little weird anything else under here
probably not oh it's a fortification
alright okay so what's under here can I
blow it all up is that something I can
do lots of good stuff okay pick this
lock
see where it takes me hopefully I can
bring some happiness and her enter
hooligan bunker Oh
hooligans oh I'm so sorry hey broom we
can whack some candy out of a rat no
warning I'm trespassing well I mean
that's the idea right Sally would have
loved this if I could never get in here
ooh wait it's a German bunker where are
we exactly
no do I really want to pick this lock
it'd be a waste em and do it if it's a
lock for a reason there's got to be
something good in it right right a
lockpick so hey paid for itself oh
that's awfully nice okay I guess I'll
take it at least I got some metal bits
[Music]
if you think I'm about to get my head
caved in
smash that lock blanton give me a big
old smoochy touch on that sweet Bell I
still have to take the elevator no one
notices why would I have to you didn't
even try the doors oh I guess that
explains itself all right let's try this
this is broad gonna go good ding-dong
nothing though Freddie lovely day here
is not many people get this bar it's
sort of a taste someone who gets this
far usually boots have a decent fight
I'm here I don't suppose there's some
way I could be more useful to you alive
I don't know
can you giggle well I could write a
lovely poem I won a prize in school now
we've already got a bad first put your
things in that box we'll leave you there
to staff okay well will I get it back
will I get it back
oh thanks alright well sure yeah I trust
you guys you look like respectable ad
buys good diner wings but I'm having the
truth my loins 48 upon you my loins are
always girded excuse you for even
assuming that my loins ain't fully 100%
gird backup goalie Oliver maybe no bing
bong ding dong oopsies oh ok alright
look bring it on come on I got some
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
are you related to willem dafoe
hi sorry I don't think I know you
of course you know me you've got me set
from the out Colin I don't remember that
I don't work there anymore you don't one
of my articles was insufficiently
original Danny the phone you you lost a
bit of weight to be fair
you didn't copy my piece line by line it
gives a [ __ ] Hastings and his paper is
about to make you feel good
nobody remembers what they've read I
don't want to fight you the feeling is
music there's only enough vote for the
winners see Oh pointy stick or a padded
branch a petit one doesn't look nearly
as effective how badly do I don't want
to kill good old Danny
well what if I want to kill him real
good what if I want to kill him I kind
of want to kill him come on come on stab
you so good you're gonna be so stabbed
are you gonna use them you can use the
Cricut back covered in baby what just
wanna go I can save my game now I'm
gonna save this but I want a good pointy
stick oh you're gonna get it now oh yeah
but good thing out cheering dudes Oh God
oh [ __ ] uh-huh all right okay all right
come on you think you got it with my
fists what the hell was like there we go
yeah
Oh No Oh stupid idiot stupid
I already know how to fight stupid idiot
he's gone Oh shove it there we go ah
teach me how to shove huh huh we're
right in the dick in the dick pin the
dick right in the dick get you in the
dick guess pointy stick to the dick you
[Applause]
[Applause]
stick your have a dick so I guess not
quite as effective and one of these boys
titties huh oh yeah it's a bit unfair to
be one but good thing I got a stick Wow
oh I'm out of stamina I'm also low on
health
ha ha ha miss me you know okay sorry
Jocasta Tullett maybe you shouldn't have
tried to team up on me that's that's
your bad that's under present your bad
please take your [ __ ] alright anyway
well I got my stick hey hey listen buddy
I did you real good huh maybe you do me
real good later not like that unless you
want it like that but anyway see you
later
All Right see you around where's my
stuff give me my [ __ ]
I'm almost dead - where's my [ __ ] I've
got like very little health oh it's a
good game this good game hey I press up
I'm going down I don't are you saying it
like that I've got a sinking feeling oh
good well ah time to search all right
nothing there
okay was there a name sandy tooth sandy
- V I got it okay all right metal bits
wait much you really qualify this as
stealing this is stealing really all
this is Celia you dumped me into a body
pit and you call it stealing
okay well huh sure whatever tweets their
own que sera sera - good Jimmy bar thank
you can i my stuff back can I stab
everybody we'd really love to give
everyone a good old stab and let me I
need this super bad trekking the quest
yeah whatever screw the quest alright
let's you lose BAM
okay that should be good alright a
muscle event hold if I can pry it loose
need a Jimmy ba wait so did these people
come down here and just not figure out
how to escape all of them I get hidden
in two seconds and maybe they were dead
one another no one is actively trying to
kill me I want to be on lookout for a
mottling dispenser that Chapa the bridge
said I need a Power Cell and his war
medals Oh
which I am a rock okay weird time for
skill points I was just staring at this
guy peein contemplating what I was gonna
do alright odd man out defensive and
sarcastic English repressed Swift runs
quite fast oh this is Who I am
Oh unremarkable can hide in plain sight
eg on benches if not in line side of
angry people okay
buff okay yeah wait forward with a
little preparation you can give someone
a real wallop Oh iron fist
Oh God look at the Slap Chop I'm gonna
pack a wallop oh no whoa make them bleed
more often blockbuster breaking an Enys
weapon that's fun
stealth Oh
smother people in their bed smooth
doctor talking to people who's gonna
talk to people Body Snatcher Church and
carry bodies more quickly drop bodies
quietly hey that's good herbal is heal
better
no I'm gonna do the pill oh man what's
with my outfit here what is this outfit
gloves in like a latex suit I'm gonna
buy this Ellie I'm gonna buy that give
me that give me a pillow
I want the pillow definitely don't want
a crowd wait did I just get the skill
that needs to be for this that's a lot
of pee by the way it was a lot of pee
wait oh and he's done wait one second I
want to hold it go back I'll save and
return to the menu god damn it I was
hoping I just wanted to see if I could
stand there if you would peeve forever
if like it would be a perpetual pee
oh well whatever all right drink from
tap vlog glug probably a lot of joy
all right he'll die damaged Elsa you
missed by the way okay please tell me
there's someone in their bed that I can
smother please tell me that's a thing
that I can do little Felix warning
Hamill's why Shh it's better this way
I don't know what that means but I said
it TV well I'd be distracting jazz salt
aha but I remember how to make a
lockpick I do I know how to do that I
already knew how to do that I'll thank
you to Carolyn Parker thank you so much
for that and thank you Matthew Westbury
thank you so much
don't know why just grab that teacup or
ration that would not still be good in
no way shape or form would that still be
good no I didn't want to sit just
resting my feet yeah that's me or
whatever and there's a lot of stuff to
search no one's in their bed no one's in
their bed was that metal bits yes please
doc DPS please head boys rule okay that
boys rule okay you know they're pretty
good at that rule and I think you know I
don't have too much of an opinion on it
how to be sneaky all right ah ah quick
slots automatically fill your inventory
press up on the beginning is to grow
through will they have to use the
equipped item it's easier to move among
your enemies if they're looking
somewhere else cause a distraction okay
makes sense to me
what kind distraction are we looking for
here Dart
glass bottle here we go does that guy
I don't understand that I don't
understand I'm not Accenture I
understand what what the benefit of that
would be but you know all right
look over there that was weird
hmm wowie wowie wowie Zowie Lorenz beat
it probably hurts probably hurts quite a
bit actually Lawrence if I'm if I'm
gonna be perfectly honest about this
Bruggen hurt a lot glass bottle steel
this is big ol lever but I can't pull it
I gots no pulling for me I'm gonna throw
this over Oh search this who did Buddha
who the heck all right to be oh no to be
same as the other two V that's good oh
this looks dangerous let me drink some
of that
hello perfectly Pleasant time please
stand up please
can I thank you alright bobby pin glass
bottle glass bottle for our shelter
purely supplemented by ma today the fuel
of the future No
okay all right I don't know what that
means and why it's being pumped down
here but okay is it not flammable is
that now what it is okay all right
whatever you say buddy go over here oh
that was me I thought it was just
someone going ahead walked up huh what
wait a minute when they jump me
all right easy as that huh easy as that
huh all right well fine quest items
first okay so I'm not done so I need to
find my quest items my quest dsds my
quest teeth where the heck is oh don't
know that's Lawrence Lawrence goddammit
what's up there here we go I found it
excuse me you need to pick this I need
the gas mask for that part that's
probably a good thing to get looks can I
read these goddamn books what happened
to book all right can go through that
Hamlet and give that chappies medals and
give me the coordinates across the
bridge yeah it's so worth it I'm so glad
that I had to murder three people to be
able to get that for them I really do
appreciate that
it was super good well thank you
Christmas master eight nine oh seven for
becoming a member of the channel thank
you so much for that all right let's see
what else we got here fill bottle and
that's it and I gather whose so much
crap I just don't know what else to do
with it all I haven't faced the part of
the game yet that I would need it but
let's go all right that was totally
worth it by the way I'm super super
duper happy I did all that stuff that
was good
that's great Thank You max oz would oh
I'm in I'm in here okay I could
disappear into those bushes oh yeah
won't bother you for sneaking one of the
bushes with yellow flowers unless they
bump into you oh whatever I'm sitting on
the [ __ ] what if I'm just sitting
[ __ ] what they noticed me then they
might not notice me if you really think
about it
you really think about it they might not
do dude there's yellow flowers were very
very stealthy going for a [ __ ] no wait
don't [ __ ] oh my god he was about to pee
please don't make a fuss
oh I ruined my chance I ruined my chance
to see the infinite P damnit damnit
it probably wouldn't have been infinite
it probably wouldn't have been probably
I don't know I was so excited but in the
first place I forget about anything I
said is there doesn't forget about
anything forget all that's no we don't
need a car Oh books bobby pin hey Amy
see it but I got it
double box more like a tool right here
get ready to be told stupid all right ed
boys suck o bottle right in the right in
the noggin huh get back wait where's my
come back get back
actually I don't even need this I'm
gonna wanna go mano-a-mano I like I
generally stab all the like the
completely innocent people but when it
comes down to like these these ed boys I
just wouldn't I'm not gonna stab them Oh
like that
let's been looking down my blocks in
nursery wait you know this guy what how
does Arthur know everybody here that's
all sad I guess a small town ed boy
fight tonight tonight will end up in the
ring ed boy fight that's right that's
where I had to fight to the death ding
ding okay whatever you say okay I bet I
didn't even need to do any of that I
probably had just come through like just
hopped over something to get in here ooh
what's in the tower
yeah let me go up in the tower first oh
I can't get in the tower what they have
at or if you can't get in it that's
stupid they're stupid that's stupid
whatever pretty dumb oh thank you to
Maryland our visas are versus B games
Emmeline McNeely lacks Trude Basti
dragon shrine
gracious Fox oh thank you so much
there's been a big surge of it lately
thank you yeah thanks all the new
members thanks for being here I
appreciate that let's see there is some
mist there
what's with the mist she's a misty mist
the ghost someone said something about
ghosts over here so maybe there's a
ghost over here no I represent sure all
right
hello do you still it wait where do you
go buddy
friend I can just climb through here
it's not really that big of deal where'd
you go okay I guess I'll pick this why
would I need to pick a file cabinet lock
yeah also there's been quite a few
people that have now earned the blue
heart in the membership thing if anybody
has a blue heart like type right now oh
well activate that yeah so I can see it
that's the two-month membership badge so
it's getting it's getting pretty cool
people are climbing up the ranks it's
super fun there's green I see green eat
the rude thank you so much shucks hello
yeah see a lot of green see a lot of red
saw good you so much my soul to be
pretty clean I'm like in the village
where they smoke it with joy okay I
don't know why this is pretty clean but
I'll take your word for it
somehow you know that they spike it with
joy over in the city okay where did this
dude go did he go to bed or something
where why would he go to bed come on I
need him here both yeah whatever vending
machine my stuff would I buy I have
money what did I get money I don't know
if lashes but sewing kit I do need that
because I need to make a suit okay so
I'm gonna make a suit because I want to
suits obviously I want one that I'm
going in to real town and then another
one that I would not want to do that
right that seems necessary there we go
now I've got a torn suit and a good suit
so I'm gonna keep the torn one for now
and go find oh he's over there outcast
oh hello today Oh looks like some
children were drawing nice things also I
have noticed there's no children
anywhere around here which is probably
indicative of what happened it's night
you know where'd he go
probably went to bed or something cuz
it's night take the joy I don't take
your joy I think I'm good
oh hello hi how are you doing oh hi
you're in here huh oh you too you too
are uncle you middle thank you
you don't know what he's mean to me to
know this some of his ball to know that
I far probably too young to remember
wish the time girls dead in 42 we from
back in to see then the game back in 43
we're in the same fine to be a bother
but the card didn't get across the
bridge right of course yeah sorry for
giving old Manny's memories oh good luck
I've got this key card and I can power
up the gate with the Power Cell okay so
I'm ready to cross the bridge okay I
guess I am but what what's the deal with
the workbench here do I actually need
the workbench for anything I don't think
I do right
it makes him healing balm I guess but
yeah I'm pretty good on health though so
I think I should be okay alright let's
get back into the thing we got to go
over to the bridge to go back into the
real town which means that I gotta get
changed in real clothes that stay out of
sight after dirt why why why would I
need to why what does that do for me
what does he do
understand but I've got flowers uh-huh
okay young these names right stripe
stripe huh
then they up here oh I don't trust that
at all
whoa whoa couldn't make some creeper if
you tried I bet they tried okay all
right Wow when will they stop crying oh
you know it was the last time there was
a baby in Wellington oils oh boy that's
creepy
Oh for anyone asking how to become a
member there's a join button down below
the video that'll take you to the page
where you can see all the benefits you
get from being a member
[Music]
okay alright I'll go upstairs probably
good idea okay just gonna stop that I
regret stopping it
I regret Oh huh Betty buy time huh
it would just smother that mannequin
there oh thanks I hate it I hate it
hello hi diddly ho ho tisha funny Leslie
never play with toys he didn't like
anything that wasn't really the thing it
was supposed to be a cool t-shirt oh
honey let's go play would thought you
didn't like anything that wasn't really
the thing it was supposed to be yeah
okay all right okay I got a disposable
safecracker oh I didn't know they even
made those to be disposable but anyway
I'm out of here
oh yes I'm done oh man things are
different at night although I'm pretty
sure that would have been exactly the
same in the daytime huh all right let's
get EOD apparently these lockpick seems
to be lasting longer so it must not just
be one and done right is that's what I
can only assume yeah let's get across
this bridge
there's a card reader right here but
dunk hazy Phase II I put on my suit and
put on my good suit let me change this
out for this one
yeah oh now we're talking and let me get
let me switch out no that's almost
broken let me get a nice um what what
what what what do I have whatever meat
key okay hooligans like to lock
themselves in the bathroom wankers yeah
probably literally what why is it a
quest item what quest what quests heal
thyself use healing balm okay I all
right
I don't understand that that's weird all
right anyway carry on potty hell I've
forgotten about the revolvers if I go
through without taking my joy I'm gonna
get spanked
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay I'm not gonna run like hell
though and I'm off to the train station
your way in this thing no okay whoa ah
weird okay la da da dee dee what do you
what it uh what allelic be dealing a lot
of nudity a lot of you this is where we
hang them isn't it I broke into the
police station tried to burn the
register so the Germans wouldn't know
which kids to take we didn't want the
Germans to be angry did we it was so
scared
well maybe just so tired so we hang them
to encourage the others I wonder if
we've made the Germans take the kids by
force instead of bringing them down to
the station singing London Bridge if
things will be different now
oh my candy almost we're candy I hope
that's the worst thing I remember says
the chap heading to the train station
brought lovely memories are waiting for
me yeah probably definitely I can get on
the train tracks then get the hell out
of town yeah need to find the train
station yeah
to be able to see it from a distance
yeah yeah yeah I know none of that none
of that
okay nom nom I don't know what these
things do night-blooming Nonsuch very
strange why is that play why would that
be out there in the middle of a field
where almost nobody is it's not even a
road through here it's just a field oh
thank you Dad dank boy 1809 three zero
and sorry I can't play for tonight with
you
okay man things are much creepier in
this game at night that's another thing
that came out of what oh sorry sorry um
sorry I did you an ed boy ed boy bonk
shovel bonk yeah I can't beat these
fists of fury huh yeah yeah yeah you
think you're tough you the answer is oh
you are oh my god you are all right well
I guess so thank you oh you're dying
from wounds well you know what so are
you buddy with the pointy stick ha there
you go that's what I thought No too late
No well he's already dead so it doesn't
matter man that guy was tough or
apparently hitting people with your
fists is really inefficient maybe that's
the one maybe that's it I am almost
dying oh I'm dying I'm literally dying
okay let's try let's try one of these
okay all better
wow that was worth it I was definitely
worth it I'm super happy about that
but why was he out here like the ed boys
what do they actually do in here are
they actually about the more flowers
over there but I don't know I was doing
no quite as grand as it used to be
of course there hasn't been a trying
since the Germans left yeah
the tracks go from here all the way to
the bridge and then across the river and
then all over Britain who wouldn't I
kill for a set hard we've promoted this
far I wonder why mr. kite sent her to
the garden district at all she could
have just popped over the bridge from
the station at Apple home good questions
all around I don't know the answer zoom
I don't think anybody does why even
bother trying to worry about it hello
what are we gonna do if there isn't food
will you shut it I'm trying not to blow
myself up I lock up your ball bounce out
piss on your corpses Jory top banger you
leaky scanner dad
boarding all the B mate I think I
might've blown himself up whoa hey buddy
how you doing hey are you okay you good
okay you good um yeah I got probably got
blowed I don't know why he got blowed
people get angry when you steal from
their houses
well they don't they don't get angry at
me specifically and this isn't exactly a
house right yeah Wally Humphries
I saw that sliding down excuse me excuse
me I saw that okay I saw that I want to
see what's in here actually before I do
anything rash well unlock it it food
over to sell you yeah pretty much that's
how it goes with most people right
nothing what was even the point then
vending machine I don't need that search
desk that lets bottle glass Bob got so
many glass bottles you'd think I would
actually be distracting people more can
i I was hoping I could sit in that I
would have been nice okay so you're over
there so that's good is he taking a piss
man these guys this is you guys take a
lot of piss whoa you can't see me what's
that over there
whoa oh who knows a bit farther Wow okay
question why would he question it I'm
sure the only thing he has through his
head is a rough tease shovel please tell
me that's a weapon
Oh required for digging also deals
moderate damage against opponents chance
it's done not durable heavy well I'll
take the branch well give someone a good
whomping okay oh did you hear that
long what the hell what the Freddy man
you or not it's me not the brightest
ball bear Freddie I'm act I imagine that
none of these guys are exactly two
hundred percent smart outside of me oh I
think I hit him it's all right what was
that well though
you asked me I've never heard of it Wow
Wow no no no hang on hang on hang on oh
no no you don't know anything I'm in a
bush you can't be me I'm in a bush is
that it is that it was that it yes Pat
wrong all right
turns out I am turns out I very am your
problem all right
oh good don't get down to the tracks hmm
you durand-ruel cédric sorry to bother
sorry to bother with some sweet
unconsciousness let me search your taint
there real quick there we go alright
easy peasy
so someone up here has food I've heard
I've heard the rumors someone here might
have some food is this journey really
necessary needless travel interferes
with the war effort
okay you don't know that mmm
watch this is sweetest maneuver you've
ever seen in your life also let me eat
some food I don't probably need to eat
something
maybe carrot rotten carrot rotten apple
that doesn't even look like an apple the
mushroom rotten - no mushrooms could get
rotten uh caltrops tea leaves rotten
potato I thought I had oh all kinds of
edible things cook together then left to
rot for a bit yep that sounds about
right war ration rady since 1943 all
right here we go
no no no that's very valuable I
shouldn't have eaten that oh there you
go okay here we go
alright let's try this good
oh wait whump whump whump whump listen
that sounds like it hurts all Lots
always be killed on and see how it in
the system
what Wow listen I'm not a murderer who's
just a branch this is a branch I mean I
am a hitting him in the brain a lot so
maybe that has something to do with it
but I wouldn't think that our branch
would be able to just kill someone
outright all the games in media often
times overplay the ability to just knock
someone unconscious without any
consequences
usually that ends up with doing some
serious damage to their future prospects
at being able to use their brain yeah so
that's pretty much not it's it's not
murder yeah yeah probably something like
that
guy Jimmy bar til money
whomp-whomp no I go oh you're removing
like this okay okay all right okay oh hi
how you doing my name is Marc Blair are
you ah - oh I get down right oh I just
have to find the tracks and walk on our
Wellington whales okay well I don't need
I don't need a torch list of names and
dates these are the list of kids aren't
they name has been crossed out Margaret
Worthing where's Arthur
should be on this right Bing to send by
taxi no maybe yeah I guess not
maybe not okay no locks good God
you cannot fight while using a torch all
right good to know
all right okay I don't like this if
you're gonna put me through a horror
routine I ain't too happy about that
candy candy gimmick your candy where'd
you go there your sweet delicious candy
raw meat candy where's the candy hmm
where to go where to go I know I haven't
I know I haven't where's the food there
it is where's around me oh oh yeah mmm
oh that's some sweet candy all right
okay now that I feel properly
rejuvenated - happy birthday Sebastian
happy birthday I can hardly believe
you're ten already of course you're such
a brave boy that you often see much
older there's a slice of carrot cake in
the box I know it's not your favorite
but we'll have to make do just a little
longer next year I hope we'll have a
proper birthday cake and candles for you
this war can't last forever is this the
cake because that is that's got to be
ancient then dear Sebastian what a brave
boy you are daddy says you got on the
train and climbed out the back into the
tunnel just like we practiced we were so
worried when we saw the train pull away
what if the windows had been locked it
was agony waiting to know you were safe
daddy says you're crossed with him for
not coming earlier but please understand
it's too risky except on days when he
can inspect the tracks daddy will bring
you food every Tuesday try to make it
last
we don't have ration coupons anymore for
you anymore but that's alright as I need
to reduce anyway courage my little
soldier PS I've asked daddy to smuggle
Aloisius to you I know you think you're
too big to sleep with a teddy bear but
it's good to have some comfort of home
no oh that's so nice that's so sweet
that's so sweet switch replacement I
don't know what I need that for but I'm
probably gonna find out
[Music]
okay all right that's so sad - oh this
is dad I'm not sure I don't know weird
okay what do we got here
ah Kurt chunk or chunk wrote it well I
got a stick in my wrist um on this stick
don't mind the stick don't mind the
stick don't pay attention to the stick
when unlocking track side door always do
be careful
yeah I do buku always do be careful okay
sure whatever you say buddy always do be
careful
oh oh I get it
what did I just do always do be careful
whoa where did that shutter go there is
a vent above the door there is no place
for that shutter to go that didn't make
any sense whatsoever okay all right yeah
sure whatever I'll let it slide for now
but you're on thin ice oh I'm sorry
Percy
I should have gone on the train with you
I got promised the rule was if a kid was
a day over 13 what could I do you could
have kept your mouth shut off there are
not told them you were 13 that's what
you could have done
I suppose yeah
now why would there still be coins in
that thing I guess if nobody came around
to collect them but hey even so doesn't
seem logical it is a sad story that they
got going on here yeah brothers separate
but what's weird about is in the
inventory screen when you can see that
this is from Arthur's perspective it
makes it seem like there's more going on
here than you would you know ordinarily
see for coin box give me your money I
guess I can always make more Jimmy bars
if they keep breaking like that that's a
lot of money that's a good bit of money
good I mean it's weird it like this game
is kind of walking the line between a
few different genres it's coming down
like in the in the weird mystery of it
but like the surreal nosov it is kind of
hiding a sad backstory like the the
happiness is to cover up so they don't
that they don't lose themselves in the
sorrow of what happened and the loss of
who they are sorry I got a dog hair in
my mouth yeah so it's kind of like I
don't know it's just fascinating to see
like the lengths that people will go to
to try to forget like the sins of the
past and and like maybe lose all hope
like otherwise no no weird cool most
weird
can't wait to see more story about it
though oh yeah I'm slow now
[Music]
and you are too old to go to Germany are
you bloody Bobby I told him I wanted to
board even if I was ten days too old but
we don't make the rules anymore mr. rice
dings I shouldn't have told him they've
got my birthday wrong I don't even know
why did should have just kept quiet and
got on the trying wait so it makes it
seem like just by the sound of it it
sounds like Percy's older but that
wouldn't make any sense
right you know what I mean it doesn't
make any sense if that is the case which
I don't think it is but you know this is
bizarre I don't know the age is a little
confusing because if Arthur was too old
to get on there then that would make
Percy younger right that's just what it
would be how the hell there's been some
sort of K V so I'm sorry so much for
walking down the train tracks to the
Britannia Bridge so much boys Bo Peep
eat your curds you are back oh that's
Little Miss Muffet you Muppet can we
tell him now yeah bird ah wait hang on
wait I'll uh joke him at the choke point
here we go pop up get one ow who throws
up a bag of flour who threw that
I'm dying apparently hang on wait let me
use one of these now just squeeze this
in my eyes real quick you can't win I've
got the high ground
oh yeah oh hang on let me put some more
on my face this guy get my eyes really
need some healing who keeps throwing
flour all right your turn
shove honk oh I got my pointy stick I
forgot to have this I really like my
pointy stick uh-huh
got him from the dick in the dick in the
neck there you go there you go now you
sleep you guys what have we come to
I don't know they jumped me shouldn't
have known I had a pointy sticking up
okay a log I carry I log with me
wherever I go it's their fault not mine
anyway
see ya what are exotic butters someone
doesn't know what exotic butters are I
can't even fathom what that even is
about I can't believe that Oh healing
balm let me put some of that in my eyes
again all right well I'll feel much
better now
anybody want some of this pointy stick
got rusty shovels too those are pretty
cool empty pill bottle nothing
Garbo hello candy candy candy candy
no candy there we go got the candy yeah
all right okay cool the candy oh yeah
yeah hello
okay out is up there but there's stuff
here maybe more candy
don't forget the control Chuck how can
anybody forget the control Jack what's
with the sad music man pick up the joy a
little bit maybe use some happiness over
here whatever I don't know where this is
going after this am I trying to get on a
train cuz that's what really doesn't
make any sense here if I am then like
where would I even be going there
there's no train that would be running
there Scott there can't be a train
that's running there just wouldn't be
that just definitely wouldn't be a thing
right absolutely would not be a thing
free metal pipe oh I can't get that that
oh there we go no runs no some stuff I
don't mind it being tediously slow going
okay fine what do I need to drop what
are you talking about what do you call
these shovels alright I'll drop that gee
don't dumb blonde go through up these
sticks maybe huh I don't know that's
probably fine so I got the hiccup perps
look at the hip burps all right let's go
up here uh hiccup candy candy thank you
thank you for your contribution okay
Kenny
anybody just get some coins kick him in
the balls doing my kicking in balls I
don't even know who I'm kicking okay
goodbye
bloody hell that's only only come from
me Javier
Lee I'm also you won't get me you won't
get me you boss that sleep no it's
authoring tools and we're gonna shoot -
OH
save you Margaret I'm your neighbor
Oh God they took him away
Oh Lee no way stop wait didn't you see
that before I like this guy
I'll save you Margaret Carty little arty
yeah [ __ ] sake which I medical idea
what would your mum think I thought they
took you away no they have my birthday
wrong what sorry you no of course not no
you've got it all wrong that was Jack
turned you in an a what tried to save
you right I remember now you came back
from the station the only one you don't
think they hurt him
Percy the Germans aren't animals you
know they just wanted to make sure we
stay quiet spot of tea that's very kind
of you I'm not thirsty that's right
Margaret we have to run after water I
have to find him any idea where he might
be after all these years
not really I know I have to get out of
Wellington Wells but I thought I could
take the train tracks to the bridge
Hey the only way to the Britannia bridge
is the train station and the parade and
good luck getting into the parade you
could stay here remember when you and
Sally is to stay with me when
it's young arty make you remember Artie
don't ya no room at the end for young
Artie no you're right
you're always right sorry Margaret says
it's best if I keep to myself oh sorry
to bother but Margaret thinks we could
help each other
really brilliant there's a warehouse in
the old German camp we can burgle it the
victory memorial camp where all those
home army chaps run around practicing
stabbing people with bayonets what you
want me to do there run around yelling
Here I am shoot me are you going under
the wire there's a thing I need from
their warehouse if you help me I'll get
you out of Wellington Wells I just need
you to turn off the power in the camp
and this isn't going to get me killed
don't be a great girls Blair's I'll meet
you at the bunker after dark
don't worry about the sentries on the
bridge I'll make sure they get a good
night's sleep okay all right Margaret so
myself El Din Oh me I don't actually
know the way out you know oh hey that's
Margaret from school Margaret what's her
name she was supposed to go on the train
but then she disappeared and no one
would talk about it
okay all right oh yeah everything's
perfectly normal here everyone's sane
and happy happy insane does any of this
stealing if I grab any of this stuff is
that kind of stealing I hope it doesn't
kind of stealing because I'm gonna grab
it anyway I just saw lies do you know
look bad you know mommy wouldn't
anything to reflect poorly on the
character okay there doesn't seem to be
anything else here okay
like it nice found the lever apparently
I like levers whose I'm up here I'm
gonna climb I like climb and climb is my
favorite like climbing clubs good I felt
I don't like falling falling is not my
favorite I like climbing not falling
there we go often puffs I'm off and off
climb often buff okay there we go
hello can I steal this apparently I did
dig spot was added to your map I have a
map oh oh of course I have a map well
then where do they get a map wait when
did I have a map what the hell oh god I
gotta go all the way oh that's a dig
spot oh that's a dig spot oh that's a
dig spot Oh what the hell did I get a
map all right whatever fine sure uh-oh
my ankles
all right okay well that's all right
where am I going
all right let's go whoa it'd probably be
bad to walk through those better rub
some ointment my guys some be ointment
oh that's better
Oh better now the Scottish play
hey I don't know maybe that guy wasn't
Scottish
we don't know I don't want to make any
assumptions here all right whatever
oh no they're a little a little uh you
didn't see nothin I'm gonna just sleep
sleep whoa what the heck do I need sleep
oh let's sleep until night again because
I want it to be sleep the pool men's
dinner I don't think that's how they say
that good citizens are home in their bed
at night if police catch you lurking
around the village at night they'd give
you a jolly thrashing a jolly thrashing
a jolly good thrashing or jolly
thrashing anyway I'm just gonna go for
it I don't want a bedtime sorry okay
good night
I'm supposed to have been rolling up the
pavements about now what well they'd be
dead old I'm not getting old were you
talking about will be bayonet if it
drills will be bad innit
you're gonna get stabbed sleeping eh
yeah user sleeping all right
all right well let's pick this lock and
go say hi to the sleeping guy give him a
nice stab
hello oh it's just a supply closet I
thought I was gonna be able to go and
see the guy oh well that's stupid
no why in this garbage one fine day the
see boys come running into the
regimental HQ saying this an elephant
broke loose elephants it's very gentle
creatures most of the time just fine
with the man who writes you have to
chain them up and this one ain't got
loose and his bow when chasing off in
exactly the wrong direction by the
elephant runs into the market and starts
eating peaches Anatole tries to stop him
and the elephant steps on him stumbling
over mashes him right into the mud and
skin comes off his back but he was
feeling so the sea boys got running
after this jingle only then he was a
major and say your mud gum should this
element so he keeps his hunting rifle to
505 games and he goes down to the
marking only now the elephant isn't in
the market anymore it's in a field
eating leaves is commish never mind son
there's no cause to shoot anymore and
when animals got my any screaming and
jabbering about
please don't you buy anything you see
he's going that way
and he don't know how to do any other
job except sitting there elephant
intelligent pick up a log and carry it
over there
bunny elephants taking the life of a man
you see a [ __ ] but a man and the moats
crying and jabbering and cruel it's a
summer breeze the general shape is
around pushing right through the
elements and all the villages are
running to get their knives because it's
free me now see that's a man would've
trembled at the thought of shooting an
elephant
it's just calmly standing there he
leaves some civilian Burma had to shoot
a rogue elephant he had to practically
empty a whole magazine the poor thing
and it was half an hour of the time but
the general makes the tough choices
so don't you armchair generals tell me
why you just follow orders I'm gonna win
the next war the generals promise
all right good story I don't know what
the moral of it but good story I guess
I'm not gonna open that door I that's I
don't understand what how why anything
you were doing but alright okay lovely
story somebody there can i smother you
in your bed
ghosts mothers guys I don't even know if
he has a pillow but gonna try to smother
a couple of grabby hands yeah yeah okay
I guess I can't do anything never mind
then what about you can I get your
bayonet hello
hmm never aim your gun at anyone you
don't want to shoot never fire your gun
at anyone you don't want to kill ok good
advice this one's super weird oh wait
are they dead or are they just asleep I
don't know not quite clear
take the Scotch though this guy's please
yes all right
hoppity-hoop ok where did I go hello oh
oh ok I'm not sure if like the stealing
mechanic makes any sense at all if I
still amazing battleship that's not the
point
we hate the Germans and that battleship
it's part of the reason the Germans are
all lords and masters right now do you
remember when they came over and all the
little boats do you mean in 1942 or in
1943 do you want people to spit so mom
and she goes to the market she doesn't
go to the market since 1945 look this is
just one of those things I can't explain
every single detail of everything to you
you mad at me I'm not you're not I mean
yes I am how mad I was mad but now I'm
not look please don't go on the Bismarck
it will get you into trouble which means
all them be in trouble alright you won't
go I couldn't go without you anyway
that's a relief hmm okay all right
another memory just a bit of [ __ ] down
no need to worry about anything all
right
oh hi I wanted that scotch but I guess
I'm good
okay what am i oh I see no [ __ ]
civilians washed better not let anyone
see me out of uniform still his uniform
still his uniform seal his uniform seal
his steel his uniform man steal his
uniform why can't I steal his uniform
fine whatever
all right dude ledee to the door that's
deadly okay doula date it up dirty you
lovely feet dude little got my sneaking
hands I'm ready to go all right anybody
No am I supposed to go whoa oh I thought
those more nooses knew sigh the swing I
don't know why anyone would need a swing
maybe the soldiers need some R&R every
once in a while no okay
is there no way in here no how do I get
in bunker do I want to go to the bunker
his bunker where I want to go is that
what I want I have no idea
bunker I guess yes it feels like the
game it feels like when they made this
game they wanted it to be a lot more
open and not not linear but now like you
know now that it's out it feels like
very linear because it's a big world
there's a lot of space here and stuff
like that and I feel like there's room
to explore on a lot of stuff but it
seems like it's very focused now but
maybe I just haven't seen all the game
yet you get down from that tree before I
chop it down no the Germans love their
list so they're taking us away on a
train to Germany you know about it don't
you
I told you that it's ridiculous oh you
all know about it just not the kids look
they've got cows they're so gonna be
proud of milk they might even have
chocolate Oh chocolate makes it all
better
they've got tanks Arthur when you
noticed are we supposed to argue with
tanks I don't want to go to Germany it's
only for a little while I think I don't
want to be a hostage calm down this
absentee oh I'll come down for tea only
for tea though well that's fine I mean
honestly
yeah honestly it's like probably like
the kids that went to Germany probably
escaped to worse fate
staying over here I mean I don't know
that for certain maybe it's maybe it's
horrible over there and maybe that's
absolutely awful maybe it's still part
of the Holocaust and all that stuff but
like it seems like what happened in this
place like like the the the people in
the UK they just they tore themselves
apart trying to forget what they did but
maybe I don't know maybe maybe it is
terrible maybe that's why people are
regretting everything like I don't know
I have no idea maybe because people
allowed it to happen like they didn't
fight like that's why they hate
themselves could be parting is such
sweet sorrow oh hello the Germans didn't
take their tanks with them when they
left I've made him up there's a hole in
the fence
inside the dump you just have to get in
here get the key and cut the power then
sneak out into the darkness while I rub
them blind
easy peasy lemon squeezy how do I cut
the power the general keeps the keys in
his desk do you want me to break into
the generals office anyway you can
Scotch the perilous fine by me alive
I'll meet you back at the train station
what if they spot me hate run they don't
have a lot of ammunition but they're
terribly handy with their bayonets for
some of their famous hot buttered
crumpets but I wouldn't recommend it
they can't run very fast at all old
farts like me uh-huh okay all right sure
why Olli let's see that map you laid on
his sleeping potion for those chaps on
the bridge
I wish I gotta read that moonshine two
bags of sugar firewater it's doesn't
help at all look at all those tanks look
at all those tanks Wow musketeer a girl
like Sally makes new friends so easily I
really stopped talking watch her go by
who's gonna kick out of that I want to
sign up when I went off joy uh is this
way this is me is it me this is me yeah
whatever okay
all right well yeah I'm gonna do
something I'm gonna sneak in there and
then hopefully it's gonna work out well
and if it doesn't then the fence in the
dump that sounds much safer than working
in by the front gate nope I'm gonna go
the front gate I'm here I don't want to
go around to the dump I've got you know
I've got something in front of me I'm
gonna go for that that's what I'm gonna
do and that's how I'm gonna do it okay
let's see dump it your own risk if you
must know dumping what we do but what we
do not like that's funny that's funny
right there that's funny all right
Oh a gramophone
berries all over the garden district
don't they I guess I can eat that he's
still a run across a hub hmm okay so uh
I guess I'll just oh distract him
attend in a space I don't want to
pretend it's beef
look out lot of stuff over there I was
very scary you don't know that
why would I need these darts why do I
need so many darts doesn't make any
sense I'm taking them anyway okay I
don't have a record me chuck them over
that way oh not there not there oh no I
didn't mean oh well we're in trouble no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no ow ow ow ow wait wait wait wait wait
hold on wait hold on
Oh this was not where else would you go
anyway fine listen wait wait wait wait
wait wait hang on hang on hang on hang
on honey you can't see me I'm in a bush
they're not Bob bombing anymore jack
okay look okay listen listen buddy
listen buddy listen buddy buddies buddy
pal pal buddies Pawel buddies all right
where's his older they're talking about
find a way into the memorial camp maybe
I'm not supposed to go this way Clark
who's worn
seems like I am it seems like I am I
just didn't I didn't I didn't know okay
oh come on guys give it up yeah I know
you're soldiers and all but geez that's
all right ah there we go
amazing ham applause I like these guys
they're funny I could have hidden there
I would have been good
okay so there's something oh ah ah peas
oh what's wrong with that guy what he's
got a red over it Oh is he bleeding from
the bottle oh that would make sense
all right um how do I can't school a
throw can I cancel throw David something
I can do
uh oh um okay I'm always dead oh but I
want the bayonet oh it's crap anyway all
right whatever I'll drop it I ain't
gonna get it mmm I need I need to put
stuff in my my other bag you know what I
mean my super bag I got shovels oh so
that's nice I don't know bottle you make
it somebody bleed to death all right all
right here goes
here goes ah it didn't go it went badly
ow
okay really all right fine
papi a took the kids to the train
station we sent them off to Germany
because of papier-mâché a papier-mâché a
gosh-darn papier-maché right Oh take
your joy take your joy is [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] I tells you I tell ye
Mattel Z it's bull bull and [ __ ]
whatever not happy a mass J where am I
going out of here know where I'm going
oh I thought that was a dude what drink
real quick nobody look
oh well I can't go really oh I can't go
through this tree oh it's tree just too
big
do girthy for me can you stand up I find
whatever oh I can't go through these
goddamn trees oh hey anybody I don't
exactly know where I'm supposed to go
but I hope I'm going in the right
direction
woo hey don't mind me and I need to drop
something else I'm right at capacity I
guess I can get rid of these branches
whatever I don't need them you can't say
they day Thursday's or what no what the
hell now what I meant
look over there hey why don't you go
oh hey ho oh yeah that's good okay Rises
scootaloo Chand bhai nobody's nobody's
there okay well these guys aren't
exactly very smart okay look at that I
don't know maybe something's going on
over there hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa oh that was weird okay hey
what's up
I don't know who's there oh [ __ ] you
know you're not okay you know what screw
this I'm out here flash oh whoa we're
going oh okay there we go
easy peasy no one knows the things II I
think it's in here yeah it's definitely
in here what I need all right
yeah they don't know where I am oh yeah
they don't know where I am okay let's
open this
I hope I don't have a lock picked it on
out craft any okay lockpick lockpick oh
I can't cuz I'm in combat I'm not in
combat I'm just relaxing I'm relaxed I'm
so relaxed so everybody can see how
relaxed I am believe me I'm the most
relaxed person in the world
look yeah I'm so relaxed
thank you dr. Roden thank you Stephanie
Reed Thank You stylo R an artsy cookie
Jade McCall doctor Odin again couch
bingo chalk Thank You miner Mike Thank
You Bogues Ella Williams thank you so
much okay I'm out of combat now okay
cool
I said the king was in general bings
office okay I don't even know what this
keys to so I'm not there's something
behind this bookcase isn't there yeah
laughs you're positive there's something
to kill of goodness something that could
open it how about fire alarm oh that's
probably not good shouldn't do that hmm
survivor healing items give someone more
health what I don't know if they heard
me like going through the shelf or what
and but they apparently everything's
okay hey whoa whoa hey well you can't
see me you can't see me you it's me the
general no no no no no no I just need a
head you god damn it why did I hit you
just bleed already says no going no no
no no none of that no that no no no no
no don't no no listen oh no no no no I'm
gonna go up here oh god I can't go up
there
come on table now you'll never get me Oh
what's finally started cuz I got stick
yeah who's your bayonet oh yeah what the
hell well you let me rub some ointment
in my eyes what are you just do to me Oh
who's on guard duty there's a mole in
the hole
alright alright sorry oh well that's not
good
a shovel saw Oh like doing anyway all
that second care of we're good to go
alright happy Pappy Debbie alright clock
maybe clever clogs I am a clever clogs
he needs underground lot the others all
can use it to get out of here once I'm
done I suppose so
okay alright we're good huh I don't want
to pull the alarm why would I pull the
I'll put the alarm on the way out I
don't want to pull the alarm now okay
where's the map okay
I can go around to the right here we go
let's go this way they'll never find me
they'll never find me they'll never find
me
never find me I'm sneaky yeah it's gonna
be nobody can see I don't know what
you're talking about but okay flowey
ease
oh you don't know that
oh wait whoa whoa listen listen listen
listen buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy no it's a German hey I'm only half
true but whoa whoa whoa hey listen
listen listen listen it's okay it's okay
it's okay it's all good
Oh get me off over off over oh oh wait
you didn't oh [ __ ]
got it
easy busy nobody knows I'm real good at
this game by the way guys I'm really
good in case you didn't know I'm real
good really good every game that is
stealth innit I am so good so
unbelievably good yeah I didn't know
that's because I'm not gonna open it and
when I get out of here I got I got to do
that when I get out of here that's what
they said Locke okay what's in here okay
that doesn't sound good talking about me
I'm not playing victim
okay where's the power thing no don't
trigger the alarm
that's not what I wanted Oh always do be
careful what all right I'm not gonna be
able to jump over the fence from this
side I know how to get out secret hatch
but that's my way out yeah I knew that I
already knew that I knew that I knew
that sneaky sneaky nobody knows whoo
now let's go run by are they gonna know
how they're gonna tell anything good
tell they ain't gonna know ain't gonna
know they ain't gonna tell how could
they know or tell they can't either no
none of those snake snake
Oh God so easy oh my god so easy one
just got a pup a squat apparently
alright thank you for that that was
great thank you a lock please and I'm
out eating and uh huh bullski that's
pretty pretty easy if I do say so myself
thanks pop Pierre my sandpaper and
[ __ ] glue pop beer Mauser now if we
can make it back to all your life let me
get out of town but fear not a lie no
conversation at all oh yes pop beer must
say where am I going
oh the wrong way of course but being
myself can not to believe these going oh
well you know never mind less and less
and less
you will freak out over too much you
know you'll just need to have a nice
break a relaxing uh crackling dip in a
pool or something get some Scotch in you
hey I guess I just go through should I
just be able to blaze through this
pretty easily I feel like I would
is this supposed to look like the the
Jesus painting I bet that is okay all
right well honey let it get honey okay
whatever baby wow that was easy you put
in you presented it like it was gonna be
an extreme challenge and uh yeah that's
pretty easy it was like I didn't even
need to sneak at all all I needed to do
is run in at full speed screaming at the
top of my lungs while ripping my pants
off and went swinging my dick in a
pinwheel and that's all I needed to be
able to get through that probably coming
the way I'd go down in the back of the
station no way you don't think my be
[ __ ] [ __ ] what [ __ ] what [ __ ] what
dingdong I'm here oh thank you - ten
Dick Wolf Run Thank You Kent the wolf
Ryan Ficino lucky gaming microtia sadaqa
acid rain Miguel Diaz roki and bal fear
vic d whoa aroma Rama with eighty
Australian dollars hey Mark bar love
your channel you got me through a hard
place and made me want to start my own
channel to help others out I want to
give you this as a thank you helping do
charities and help out as much as you
have one day all the best Ida bomb
gaming two three eight thank you so much
hello how's Margaret Margaret doing
we're good and hello
what oh I gotta meet him up in his Tower
okay I guess weird mechanism and all
that but alright hello Oh [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] oh what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that
and [ __ ] you
oh whatever oh that's such [ __ ] I'll
rub some balm in my eyes ha stupid
that's - [ __ ] you
there we go not falling this time right
thank you thank you very much stupid
piece of poopie well you got say for
yourself ollie only where are you oh my
god Ollie are you kidding me
Ollie what is this [ __ ] where am I
going
there's something here I can collect
something I need something good for me
no books reading learning nothing
nothing at all
well what do you got up here Kurt chunk
a pig okay here I am I guess did you
know the power switch was a lot they're
all quite mad you know to come back did
you know the power switch was a long
they want another goal
he knew how would I have known that
for [ __ ] sake Artie times are hard but
you and I go back aways the tanks war
horror Olli what's that tank armor the
tanks they're made of papier-mache
papier we could have bought them if they
didn't really have tanks no I wouldn't
have given them Percy and the others I
wouldn't had to lie my way off that
train oh my god I like my way off that
train I wasn't too old to go you don't
forget a thing like that
didn't you hear me I convinced the
Germans they have my birthday wrong
if it was only me I'll just take my
happy pills and sleep through the end of
the world by promised I promised Percy
I'd keep him safe while we were in
Germany you promised to help me get to
the bridge the one in the parade on
Apple home how would you even get to it
you can't even go to Maiden home they'll
shut that bridge down last week no
you're right you're always right ever
see one of these yes do haven't the
foggiest but supposing you took this to
the bridge amazing form and supposing
you told the bobbies you were there to
fix the bridge works it might enhance
your credibility and from maiden home I
can get to Apple home an Apple home has
the only bridge out of Wellington wells
see easy peasy lemon squeezy well then
see you on the other side I'd rather
date that at you Artie good luck oh I'm
gonna see Olli anymore what are all
those cool Molotov cocktails that you
got over there can I have some of those
good oh you don't lock me out
Oh Olli come on oh what a dick all right
well that's dawn I suppose go drank
myself down again all over the place oh
well well I got what I needed to get and
I think anyway quest found Oh behave
this is what the British humor yeah wait
wait
I think that's gonna do it for today I'm
gonna get out of here I've got other
stuff that I want to work on but thank
you for joining me for we happy few I
don't know how much longer is in the
game and I don't know if that's like if
if I'll finish it in another episode or
whatnot but I do want to come back to
this eventually and I will come back to
this I've got other stuff that I want to
work on for now so thank you everybody
so much for joining me for this hope you
guys have a great day thank you for much
for being here thank you everybody that
became a member joined the channel thank
you everybody that gave super chat but
again you don't need to give super chat
at all I appreciate that so much but
take care everyone and have a great one
so thank you again and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]